so wheat spoke for Constantine for the
15th anniversary at the Comic-Con panel
Keanu and I yeah was it that panel that
actually opened the door to the
Constantine 2 stuff how did this
actually no I mean it's really and I
think this it's a you know I can have a
larger conversation we do about it on
the phone but you know it's something
that we've been talking about since we
made Constantine because we all loved it
so we've been talking about it talking
about it talking about it but uh all the
sort of DC because vertigo is part of DC
that sort of like the control of those
properties got complicated with Warner
Brothers with DC with JJ's deal you know
all those kinds of things there's a lot
of complicating factors so it was never
like Akiva and Keanu and I happen to be
sort of convinced to do it it was really
trying to figure out how we can get some
sort of control over the Constantine
character again
and honestly I think it was a little bit
of the panel but I I believe it was
keanu's appearance on Colbert
where he was asked what character he'd
love to play again and he said John
Constantine in the crowd went nuts and
people finally saw that and went oh wait
maybe you guys can go and make the
Constantine sequel
so
it was I think it was sort of a a
variety of factors